we live our lives is changing to reduce
damaging greenhouse gases
big businesses already face carbon taxes
but downing street is considering other
ways to deter us from carbon intensive
choices
including paying more at the butchers
would you be prepared to pay a carbon
tax on things like meat and cheese
yes i would because it costs to
it costs the environment to produce
those things so
i don't see why not i don't think so now
because i think these times now are hard
enough
with people getting unemployed plus the
covid thing and i think that
people shouldn't be getting extras put
on them carbon taxes could be levied on
all sorts of products and services
from gas heating to the production of
cheese
it's hugely unfair on british farmers
when they're so engaged
and ahead of many other countries in in
their environmental journey you know
many of them are investing heavily in
renewables
improving biodiversity and they're
really on board with the journey
the government has announced some high
profile policies like an
end to the sale of new petrol and diesel
cars by 2030
but in the year it hosts the landmark
cop26 climate conference
there's an expectation of bold decision
making on how to reduce emissions
which is why plans for a new coal mine
here off the cumbrian coast
have been met with incredulity the
backlash against the decision made last
year
isn't going away in an open letter the
former nasa scientist james hansen
described government support for the
mine as humiliating writing
prime minister johnson your actions and
decisions now
will either establish or undermine your
claim
to climate leadership becca willis's job
is to work out
how to keep the public on side whilst
tackling
climate change when you have a
government that is you know suggesting a
carbon tax on the one hand
and approving new coal mines on the
other hand
that's really problematic at the very
best it's confusing for people
and at the worst actually it's it's
irritating and will actually turn people
against
the uh that they need to tackle climate
change altogether
what becomes of this site for the
proposed coal mine will have
ramifications beyond cumbria
in this critical year for tackling
climate change
lisa holland sky news